president biden looking pretty foolish
after boasting right before christmas
that he had averted the supply chain
crisis
the much predicted crisis didn't occur
packages are moving
gifts are being delivered shelves are
not empty
but try telling that to americans
flooding social media with photos of
empty stores and the hashtag bare
shelves biden
it's not just social media local news
outlets also reporting on how people
can't find certain products when they go
shopping and i know jesse's been having
a hell of a time finding moose uh but
we're working on it uh you know jesse
only i i i'm gonna sound like a red meat
delivery delivery man but only a
democrat could create scar scarcity in
the most abundant country we've ever
seen in the history of the world and
only why does this only happen when
there are democrats i don't get it i
love red meat i'm glad you asked me that
question greg what happened was
everybody caught the crown over
christmas and then they came back to
work got tested tested positive and then
their boss made them quarantined for
five to ten days and thousands of these
people work in food supply and
distribution and that's why you're
seeing a lot of empty shelves on the
store and it's creating scarcity so
there's a fear factor because prices are
going up and there's economic anxiety
because people can't afford it and joe
just isn't tethered to that economic
anxiety the rise in the cost of living
and that's why he's getting hammered
right now but i myself
have suffered from empty store shelves
we shop where we get the groceries
delivered to you know maximize
efficiency and the woman from the
grocery store called me and she said mr
waters we do not have the bone in ribeye
ah not the bone-in we only have the
boneless rib eye and i said fine it's
not the same and then she said uh mr
waters we don't have the hickory smoked
bacon we only have the apple wood oh and
i'm like now i'm getting nervous and
then she said finally mr waters we just
have run out of the chicken liver pate
yeah are we living in venezuela i don't
i mean what are we doing here people
yeah so you truly in this pandemic you
truly are a first responder when it
comes to gourmet food
and it's because you're there that we
learn about these shortages
you're doing uh you're doing god's work
uh you know degan the problem
you know jesse brought up the thing
about how biden is untethered really to
this anxiety
but he was sold to us as political xanax
right we did four years of trump meth
and we were supposed to all relax now
because we got joe biden and it turns
out it's not that he's calm it's that
he's untethered to the anxiety he's
oblivious to all the crap that we're
going through and we thought that that
would be calming but it's actually the
opposite and he doesn't even try to hide
the fact that he's completely
disconnected from reality
well who told him about the high price
of meat
remember it was like
marianne
somebody told me they couldn't get the
bacon at the store
it is a hardship not an inconvenience
for most americans and tomorrow morning
we're going to get the consumer price
index for
december it's going to be up uh
seven percent year over year highest in
almost 40 years
so the american people already know this
um by the way my my store shelves in my
neighborhood are bare because of
thievery and shoplifting not because of
supply shortages but i will tell you
that jay powell the head of the federal
reserve has come out and said
in essence i paraphrase i'm not playing
your reindeer games anymore joey
they're going to start tightening
monetary policy they're not going to be
buying any more treasury debt see
they've been sopping up more than half
the treasury debt issued by these spin
thrift democrats they're going to start
raising interest rates because inflation
is a concern and they're going to start
reducing that what 9 trillion dollar
balance sheet it's he's fighting
inflation jay pal ahead of the fed but
it's going to get ugly for joey and
company you know uh geraldo there's
nothing wrong with saying this this too
shall pass but that's not a strategy
that's a comfort and it look it feels
like that's biden's only thing it's like
well this will this will happen and then
everything will be fine but he's not
actually help the only thing he's
passing is gas
but but
aside from the flatulence i think that
this too shall pass
you know biden is biden is unlucky he
didn't expect the country to be this
successful economically speaking he
didn't expect people recovering from
being cooped up for a couple of years to
want to spend money even as prices were
going up people still wanted to buy
demand is still intense
and i think that ultimately is a good
thing and
unemployment just 3.9 percent he should
really be singing the virtue of an
economy that's humming and i think that
powell and the the fed guys will control
inflation uh in the next quarter or so
i'm i'm not uh
frightened by it i think that bare
shelves now will mean abundant shelves
in a couple of weeks what do you say to
that dana well we should all be so lucky
right i mean i don't know if luck is
really what we're hoping for i will tell
you i was a victim of the bare shelves
not so much well but when i didn't feel
well over christmas my mom said you need
to get chloroseptic spray and i love
that stuff as a kid when i used to get
strep throat so peter goes out goes to
all the stores there's no cold medicine
the only thing that they had for a sore
throat was something that like a spray
for children so i got that and then i
ended up passing it on to the fritz
family because it's not very good
the fritz the fritz i knew it was gonna
always gets back to the fritz but i only
have 10 seconds i always i can bring
them up yeah you know i went to the
furniture store and you know what i
noticed
in the uh
the shelves were full of shelves
so there you go
you know it seemed more interesting in
my head before it came out of my mouth
which explains my entire life hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else